This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In one of the most famous episodes of the TV show Seinfeld, the character Elaine, played by Julia Louis-Dreyfus, takes to the dance floor. Alright, because dancing! Come on, who's dancing? What follows is hard to describe. Elaine's dancing resembles a giraffe navigating an ice skating rink on roller skates.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在电视剧《宋飞正传》最著名的剧集之一中，由朱莉娅·路易斯-德莱弗斯饰演的角色伊莱恩走上了舞池。好吧，因为跳舞！来吧，谁在跳舞？接下来发生的事情很难描述。伊莱恩的舞姿就像一只长颈鹿穿着旱冰鞋在溜冰场上行走。
Elaine's co-workers watch with Mouts a game as her hands and feet fly off in different directions. Here's the thing though, no one tells her she is a bad dancer. Later behind her back, her friends George and Jerry discuss Elaine's dancing. Have you ever seen Elaine dance? It's more like a full-body dry heave, set the music. Did she do the little kicks and the thumbs? What, you mean you know about this? It's one of those problems I hope would just go away.
伊莱恩的同事们看着她手脚乱舞，像是在玩游戏。但问题是，没有人告诉她她跳得很糟糕。后来在背后，她的朋友乔治和杰瑞讨论了伊莱恩的舞姿。你见过伊莱恩跳舞吗？那更像是一种全身性的干呕，配上音乐。她做了那些小踢腿和竖大拇指的动作吗？什么，你是说你知道这件事？这是我希望它能自动消失的问题之一。
There's only one friend who is willing to tell Elaine the truth. Kramer, the character in the show, who often says and does things that are socially inappropriate. When Elaine breaks into her trademark dance moves in front of him, he asks her what she thinks she is doing. Stanthi! No, that ain't dancing, Sally. It ain't fun! Are you stink?
只有一个朋友愿意告诉伊莱恩真相。克莱默，剧中的那个角色，他经常说出和做出一些在社交场合不恰当的事情。当伊莱恩在他面前跳起她标志性的舞步时，他问她以为自己在做什么。斯坦西！不，那不是跳舞，萨利。那一点也不好玩！你是不是臭了？
All of us notice things about the people in our lives. We noticed oddities about our friends, co-workers, family members. We see their flaws and foibles. And even though we say we care about them, what do we do? Often nothing. We let them flounder in blissful ignorance. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore the difficulty of sharing unpleasant feedback and new psychological insights about how to navigate difficult conversations. He doesn't know what he's talking about.
我们所有人都会注意到生活中人们的一些事情。我们注意到朋友、同事、家庭成员身上的怪癖。我们看到了他们的缺点和弱点。即使我们说我们关心他们，我们又做了什么呢？通常什么都不做。我们让他们在幸福的无知中挣扎。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨分享不愉快反馈的困难，以及关于如何处理困难对话的心理学新见解。他不知道自己在说什么。
I'm a good dancer, right? I forgot to make my bed. Many of us have a complicated relationship with honesty. On the one hand, we are taught it's important to tell the truth, always, without exception. On the other hand, we often receive messages about the value of shading or softening the truth so that we don't hurt someone's feelings. These opposing dictates can leave us in a bind. At Carnegie Mellon University, psychologists Teah Cohen studies this tension and what we can do about it.
我是个好舞者，对吧？我忘了铺床了。我们许多人与诚实有着复杂的关系。一方面，我们被教导要始终如一地讲真话，没有例外。另一方面，我们经常收到关于掩饰或软化真相的价值的信息，这样我们就不会伤害别人的感情。这些相互对立的指令可能会让我们陷入困境。在卡内基梅隆大学，心理学家蒂亚·科恩研究了这种紧张关系以及我们能对此做些什么。
Teah Cohen, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. Happy to be here. Teah, I understand that as a child, you once received a gift of a jogging suit from an aunt, and you didn't care very much for this gift. Can you tell me that story? Sure. So this example is from when I was three or four years old. My anpanise gave me a pink jogging suit for Hanukkah or my birthday,
蒂亚·科恩，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。蒂亚，我听说你小时候曾收到姑姑送的一套慢跑服作为礼物，但你不太喜欢这个礼物。你能给我讲讲那个故事吗？当然。这个例子是我三四岁的时候。我的姑姑在光明节或我生日时送了我一套粉红色的慢跑服，
and as a child, maybe less so now, there was no way I was going to wear anything pink. And according to my family, I took one look at it and said, but I hate it. And my mother, of course, was embarrassed, and she apologized. Luckily, I don't think my Anperness, who's now 90 years old, I don't think my amperace, who's now 90 years old. I don't think she was too offended. But the story continues to live on in family lore in nearly 40 years later as this example of my tendency towards honesty.
作为一个孩子，也许现在没那么严重了，我绝不可能穿任何粉红色的东西。据我家人说，我看了它一眼就说，但我讨厌它。我母亲当然很尴尬，她道歉了。幸运的是，我不认为我那现在90岁的姑姑，我不认为我那现在90岁的姑姑。我不认为她太被冒犯了。但这个故事在近40年后仍然作为我倾向于诚实的例子在家族传说中流传。
So of course, lots of children say exactly what's on their minds. But I understand as you went through school, you continued to favor forthrightness as your standard policy. And in middle school, I understand you once gave your mom feedback on something she was wearing. And that incident has also become something of a family story. Can you tell me what happened?
所以当然，很多孩子会说出他们心里的真实想法。但我了解到，随着你上学，你继续坚持直率作为你的标准准则。在中学时，我听说你曾对你妈妈穿的衣服给过反馈。那件事也成了家族故事的一部分。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？
Yes. So I was in seventh or eighth grade. My mom was in the bedroom getting changed. She got with some friends. I was in the hallway outside and I looked at her with some friends. I was in the hallway outside. And I looked at her and I said, you're going out in that. And she was a little taken aback
是的。当时我在七年级或八年级。我妈妈在卧室里换衣服。她要和一些朋友出去。我在外面的走廊里，我看着她和一些朋友。我在外面的走廊里。我看着她说，你打算穿成那样出去吗？她有点吃惊，
because she thought she looked good, but she was appreciative and she changed. And she told me later she recalled thinking that, wow, this is the beginning of the teenage years. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Would you say that your family valued such honesty, or was it frowned upon here? Definitely valued. It's say my family is more direct and honest than many.
因为她觉得她看起来不错，但她很感激，于是她换了衣服。她后来告诉我，她记得当时想，哇，这是青春期的开始。哈哈哈哈。你会说你的家庭重视这种诚实吗，还是在这里不被赞成？绝对重视。可以说我的家庭比许多家庭更直接、更诚实。
There's nothing that was off limits in terms of what we could talk about. So after you grew up and entered the workplace as a junior professor, you and other young scholars got advice on how to conduct yourselves in meetings with senior colleagues. What kind of advice did you get? So, I've heard this advice where sometimes people tell junior employees or new faculty to stay silent, not say too much in meetings, things along those lines. So, to keep your head down, basically. Yeah, protect yourself.
在我们可以谈论的话题方面，没有什么是不被允许的。所以当你长大并作为一名初级教授进入职场后，你和其他年轻学者得到了关于如何在与资深同事的会议中表现自己的建议。你得到了什么样的建议？所以，我听到过这种建议，有时人们告诉初级员工或新教员要保持沉默，在会议上不要说太多，诸如此类的事情。所以，基本上就是低调行事。是的，保护你自己。
You don't want to say the wrong thing and upset someone else who's might be more powerful or higher in status, so better to just not express your opinions or preferences. Now, did you follow this advice to you? No, I don't think I did. Release not generally. And that I, if I had opinions or preferences, I would try and communicate them,
你不想说错话而惹恼其他可能更有权势或地位更高的人，所以最好不要表达你的意见或偏好。那么，你听从了这个建议吗？不，我不认为我听从了。至少通常没有。如果我有意见或偏好，我会尝试沟通它们，
you know, do so in a way that was diplomatic. But I don't think I held back so much of conveying my interest or preferences when I had them. Hmm. What about your peers, your junior faculty peers? Were they more circumspect in meetings? There were certainly some examples I can think of, you know, from the past, where I observed colleagues staying silent or maybe communicating indirectly about what they wanted
你知道，以一种外交的方式去做。但我不认为我在有兴趣或偏好时，在传达它们方面有太多保留。嗯。你的同龄人，你的初级教员同龄人呢？他们在会议上更谨慎吗？我当然能想到过去的一些例子，我观察到同事们保持沉默，或者可能间接地传达他们想要的东西，
and it was really hard to figure out what their true preferences were for the different group decisions that we were making. In other words, they wouldn't speak up in meetings or they would be elliptical in what they said. Yeah, both. Either not speaking up or not communicating very clearly about what their true preferences or priorities or underlying interests were. So if we're talking about who is going to teach
真的很难弄清楚他们对我们正在做出的不同群体决策的真实偏好是什么。换句话说，他们不会在会议上发言，或者他们说的话含糊其辞。是的，两者都有。要么不发言，要么不清楚地传达他们真实的偏好、优先事项或潜在的兴趣。所以如果我们谈论的是谁将教
which courses or serve on different committees, things along these lines, you know, we're trying to figure out what each person preferred to do, you know, why, what was important to them, and it could be really frustrating if we couldn't figure that out. Now, it's possible that of course that your colleagues didn't have strong preferences about what they actually wanted. That's true. I think in some cases people did, and it would come out later after the fact if they weren't happy with the group decision
哪些课程或在不同的委员会任职，诸如此类的事情，你知道，我们试图弄清楚每个人更喜欢做什么，你知道，为什么，什么对他们很重要，如果我们弄不清楚这一点，可能会非常令人沮丧。当然，你的同事可能对他们真正想要的东西没有强烈的偏好。这是真的。我认为在某些情况下人们是有偏好的，如果他们对群体决策不满意，或者群体没有充分考虑他们的利益和他们想要的东西，这些偏好会在事后显露出来。然后我可以看到，如果小组成员对此保持沉默，只有在事后才会发现他们对决定不满意。所以随着你职业生涯的发展，你主要的专业隶属关系之一是“国际冲突管理协会”。在你加入该组织董事会后的某个时候，你从一位对组织运作方式感到沮丧的学术同事那里听到了消息。你的同事告诉了你什么，你是如何尝试解决这个问题的？所以这是一次我们正在为年度会议做计划的经历。在这个组织中，每年夏天都有一次会议，而在春天，会做出关于接受哪些论文的决定。组织中的人们需要知道论文是否被接受，这样他们就可以开始安排行程。这次会议在世界各地不同的地点举行。所以旅行可能会很广泛。所以在这个特定的情况下，我正在和一位同事交谈，她很沮丧，因为她想知道她的论文是否被接受，
or that the group didn't fully take into consideration their interests and what they wanted. And then I could see that if members of the group stayed silent about it and only after the fact it would come out that they were not happy with the decisions. So as you went on in your career, one of your chief professional affiliations was with a group called the International Association for Conflict Management. And at some point after joining the Board of the Organization, you heard from an academic colleague who was frustrated by the way the organization operated. What did your colleague tell you and how did you try and fix the problem? So this was an experience where we were planning for our annual conference. So in this organization, there's a conference every summer and in the spring, different
或者该团体没有充分考虑到他们的利益和诉求。我能看出，如果成员们对此保持沉默，事后才流露出对决策的不满，会发生什么。随着职业生涯的发展，你主要的专业隶属关系之一是“国际冲突管理协会”。在加入该组织理事会后的某个时间点，你听到一位学术同事对该组织的运作方式感到沮丧。你的同事告诉了你什么，你又是如何尝试解决这个问题的？这是一次我们筹备年度会议的经历。在这个组织中，每年夏天都会举行一次会议，而在春天，不同的
decisions are made about which papers to accept. And people in the organization need to know whether the paper has been accepted so they can start making travel arrangements. And this conference is held in all different locations across the world. So travel can be extensive. And so in this one situation, I was talking to a colleague who was frustrated because they wanted to know whether their paper was accepted,
这样她就可以制定旅行计划。当时我是该组织董事会的成员。我没有直接参与所有的会议规划，但我说，我会发一封电子邮件，我会找出发生了什么，某种程度上激励会议主席更快地做出决定，并传达出来，因为我同意她的观点，即这些决定发布得太晚了。所以我回到办公室，给项目主席以及几位
so they could make travel plans. And I was on the board of the organization at that time. I wasn't directly involved in all the conference planning, but I said, I'll send an email, I'll find out what's going on, kind of motivate the conference chair to make faster decisions, communicate that out, because I agreed with her that it was late for these decisions to be coming out. So I went back to my office, I sent this email to the program chair, as well as several
参与会议规划的董事会成员发送了这封电子邮件，我问发生了什么，为什么会有这种延迟，人们需要制定计划，并且非常直接地谈到了我与同事讨论过的问题。好吧，我在这封邮件中包括的一位董事会成员立即联系了我，说我刚刚写给会议主席和董事会的这封邮件是不恰当的。哇。这很伤人，因为我通过发送这样一封直接的电子邮件和公开的电子邮件公开羞辱了这个人。
board members who were involved with conference planning, and I asked what was going on, why was there this delay, that people needed to make plans, and it was very direct about the problems that I had talked with my colleague about. Well, one of the board members who I included in this email contacted me immediately and said that this email I had just written to the conference chair and the board was inappropriate. Wow. It was hurtful that I publicly humiliated this person by sending such a direct email and public email.
这件事的另一个方面是该组织是国际性的，会议主席来自美国以外的一个国家，那里的沟通规范要间接得多。我明白了，所以我的电子邮件在那方面是双重冒犯。所以我的电子邮件在那方面是双重冒犯。你对这个反馈感到吃惊吗？因为你觉得我没有做任何冒犯的事情？你对这个反应感到惊讶吗？我当时发邮件时并没有想到这会让人尴尬或受伤。因为我不认为我一定要以那种方式沟通。
The other aspect of this was the organization was international and the conference chair was from a country outside the US where Norms for communication are much more indirect. I see so my email was doubly offensive on that front. So my email was doubly offensive on that front. Were you taken aback by this feedback? Because did you feel like I had done nothing offensive? And you were surprised by the reaction? I didn't think of it at the time when I sent the email how this could be embarrassing or hurtful. Because I didn't think I necessarily communicated in that way.
但事后当它引起我的注意时，我意识到因为邮件中包含了其他人，而且它是对问题如此直接的陈述，它肯定会被那样理解。所以我事后对此感到难过。不仅仅是蒂亚的直率风格被视为粗鲁。她的沟通方式与同事之间似乎存在根本性的不匹配。她有时觉得别人在对她进行粉饰或隐瞒关键信息。
But after the fact when I was brought to my attention, I realized how because there's other people included on the email and it was such a direct statement of the problem, that it could certainly be taken that way. And so I felt bad about that afterwards. It wasn't just that Tia's fore-threat style was seen as rude. They seemed to be a fundamental mismatch between her method of communicating and that of her colleagues. She sometimes felt others were sugarcoding things to her or withholding critical information.
当她成为国际冲突管理协会主席时，她感觉到有些人并没有说出他们真实的想法。当我担任这个组织的主席时，我们制定并实施了几项政策改革以改善我们的治理。我们正在努力的一项改革需要会员投票，并且有一段时间让人们提供反馈或建议。所以我们在那个评论期间没有收到太多的反馈。该修正案以压倒性的支持通过了。
When she became president of the International Association for Conflict Management, she got the sense that some people were not saying what they really thought. When I was present this organization, we developed and implemented several policy changes to improve our governance. And one of the changes we were working on required a vote from the membership, and there was a period for people to provide feedback or suggestions. And so we didn't receive too much feedback during that comment period. The amendment passed overwhelming support.
然而，后来我发现有几个人对这些变化有顾虑并投了反对票。他们从未与我或董事会的其他人分享这些原因。直到今天，我真的不知道他们的顾虑是什么。所以我感觉这种情况损害了我对他们的一些信任，因为我不知道他们的立场。我无法依靠他们告诉我他们的想法或他们拥有的点子。所以如果他们与我或董事会的其他人沟通了他们的顾虑，我们也许能够修改政策以纳入这些想法，使它们变得更好，或者
However, later I came to find out that there were a few people who have concerns about the changes and voted against it. They never shared those reasons with me or others on the board. And to this day, I don't really know what their concerns were. And so I feel like the situation damaged some of the trust I had for them because I didn't know where they stood. And I wasn't able to rely on them to tell me their thoughts or ideas they had. And so if they had communicated their concerns with me or with others in the board, we may have been able to revise the policies to incorporate those ideas, to make them better, or at
至少讨论它们，给他们一些背景或解释，说明我们为什么要实施这些变化。所以，这次经历向我强调了在担任领导角色时接收反馈的一些挑战，你知道，很难知道人们有什么顾虑，因为通常存在一种不愿向上级传达关键信息或反馈的意愿。这里有一种讽刺，因为这是国际冲突管理协会。这种讽刺我也没错过。
least discuss them to give them some context or explanation for why we were implementing these changes. So, this experience highlighted to me some of the challenges to receiving feedback, serving them leadership role, you know, it's difficult to know what concerns people have because there's often this unwillingness to communicate critical information or feedback upwards. There's some irony here that this is the International Association for Conflict Management. The irony is not lost on me either.
蒂亚的经历绝非个例。在世界各地大大小小的组织中，在家庭内部和人际交往环境中，人们对于他们能多直率地说话以及他们希望别人多直率地对他们说话有着不同的看法。我们大多数人都曾在这个困境中挣扎。是诚实并分享我们脑海中的真实想法更好吗？还是为了保护人们的感情而保持友善、有所保留更好？当我们回来时，将探讨关于这个困境的研究见解以及如何解决它。
Taya's experience is hardly unique. An organization's big and small around the world, within families and in interpersonal settings, people have different views about how bluntly they can speak and how bluntly they want others to speak to them. Most of us have struggled with this quandary. Is it better to be honest and to share exactly what is on our minds? Or is it better to be nice to pull our punches for the sake of protecting people's feelings. When we come back, research insights into this dilemma and how to resolve it.
你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家蒂亚·科恩在自己的生活中注意到，她直率的说话方式有时会被视为粗鲁。她也注意到其他人通常会含糊其辞或晦涩难懂，而不是直接说出他们的想法。她想得越多，就越意识到困难和尴尬的对话为人性提供了一个窗口。它们揭示了我们思维方式中的断层线。她最终意识到，人们并不总是因为
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Taya Cohen has noticed in her own life that her forthright manner of speaking sometimes comes across as rudeness. And she has also noticed that other people can often be elliptical or opaque instead of just saying what is on their minds. The more she thought about it, the more she realized that difficult and awkward conversations provide a window into human nature. They reveal a fault line in the way our minds work. She eventually came to see that people don't always avoid difficult conversations because
他们是懦夫而避免困难的对话。他们避免说出他们真实的想法，是因为他们感到在两个强大的道德准则之间挣扎。所以，我想到了仁慈与诚实之间的这种困境，我们经常认为我们必须在这两种价值观之间进行权衡，我们必须友善，或者给予虚假的希望、鼓励或赞美，而不是残酷的诚实。我的意思是，“残酷的诚实”这个词暗示诚实必须是伤人的，我不认为这一定是这样。
they are cowards. They avoid saying what they really think, because they feel torn between two powerful moral imperatives. So, I think of this dilemma between benevolence and honesty, where we often think we have to trade off between these two values, that we have to be kind and off or false hope or encouragement or praise versus brutal honesty. I mean that term brutal honesty suggests that honesty has to be hurtful and I don't think that that necessarily has to be the case.
所以你的研究发现，人们对诚实的恐惧导致他们在对话中犯下一些可预测的错误。其中一个错误是在传达负面反馈时过于积极。谈谈这个观点，蒂亚。这是怎么发生的？所以我们经常高估诚实对话的伤害程度，我们过多地关注我们自己、对方的即时情绪。而我们忽略了考虑诚实的信息可能有多么有帮助和有用。
So your research has found that the fierce people have around being honest, lead them to make some predictable mistakes and mistakes in conversations. And one such mistake is to be overly positive in the way they communicate negative feedback. Talk about this idea, Taya. How does this happen? So we often overestimate the magnitude of harm of our honest conversations, that we focus a lot on the immediate emotions of ourselves, of the other person. And we neglect to consider how helpful and useful the honest information could be.
所以这可能发生在绩效评估中，沟通可能是间接的或涉及更多的赞美，或者他们省略了信息。有时人们使用“反馈三明治”，这是一种技术，人们找到一些积极的信息，并试图迅速将一些负面信息埋在中间，然后以更多的积极信息结束。这可能导致反馈接收者感到非常困惑，并没有完全理解问题的根源
So this can happen in performance reviews where the communication might be indirect or involve more praise, or they omit information. Sometimes people use a feedback sandwich, which is a technique where people find some positive information, and they try and quickly bury some negative information in the middle, and then end with more positive information. And that can lead to feedback recipients being really confused and not fully understanding the source of the problem
或者他们如何能够因此而改进。事实上，我了解到有一些研究表明，有时主管特别倾向于给表现不佳的人积极的反馈，因为他们担心如果他们给他们诚实的反馈，表现不佳的人会不喜欢他们。是的，他们可以专注于不伤害这些人的感情，而他们忽略考虑的是，通过未能向他们提供他们需要的信息，这实际上对表现不佳的人造成了进一步的伤害。因为现在表现不佳的人没有机会学习他们做错了什么，而且如果他们不知道问题是什么，也不一定有支持他们
or how they might be able to improve because of it. And in fact, I understand there's been some research that suggests that sometimes supervisors are especially prone to give positive feedback to poor performers because they're worried that the poor performers would like them less if they give them honest feedback. Yes, they can focus on not hurting the feelings of these people and what they're neglecting to consider is that by failing to provide them with the information that they need, that that's actually causing further harm to the poor performers. Because now the poor performers don't have an opportunity to learn what they're doing wrong, and there's not necessarily support for them to
发展的机会。我们参与的另一种有问题的策略被称为“paltering”（含糊其辞）。这对你意味着什么？什么是“paltering”？这对你意味着什么？什么是“paltering”？“Paltering”是使用真实的陈述来误导他人。所以这有时发生在谈判中，也许有人被问到一个他们不想回答的问题，所以他们会说一些技术上正确，但旨在在对方心中引起错误印象的话。想象一下你正在买车，你问卖家车况是否良好，你知道它运作得如何，他们说，嗯，有一个全新的变速器，这是真的，但他们回答的方式旨在引导你远离
develop if they don't know what the problem is. Another problematic strategy we engage in is called paltering. What does this mean to you? What is what is paltering? What does this mean to you? What is what is Paul Turing? Paul Turing is using truthful statements to mislead others. And so this happens sometimes in negotiation where maybe someone's asked a question that they don't want to answer and so they'll say something that's technically true, but intended to give rise to a misimpression in the other person. Imagine you are looking to buy a car and you ask the seller if the car is in good shape, you know how is it working and they say well there's a brand new transmission which is true but the way they've answered it is designed to lead you away
询问关于引擎的问题，而引擎是有问题的。那么给我一个组织环境中的例子，一个人给另一个人反馈。你认为“paltering”是如何运作的？有人要求对他们的演示文稿进行反馈，反馈提供者如实告诉他们，他们认为幻灯片中的颜色很棒，而且他们，你知道，有很棒的图形，你知道，他们本质上是在提供赞美，这是真的，但如果他们利用这一点来误导或引起他们认为演示文稿非常精彩的印象，如果这不是他们认为真实的情况，那么这可能是一个“paltering”的例子，或者至少是一个未能
from asking questions about the engine, which is having problems. So give me an example in an organizational setting where one person is giving feedback to another. How would paltering work, do you think? Someone asked for feedback on their presentation, and the feedback provider truthfully tells them that they thought the colors in their slides were great and that they, you know, had great graphics, you know, they're providing praise essentially, and it's true, but if they're using that to mislead or give rise to the impression that they thought the presentation was wonderful, if that's not what they believe to be true, then that could be an example of Paul Turing, or at least an example of failing
诚实沟通的例子。但是，是的，另一个例子，也许除了直接的反馈之外，是当你想到工作面试时，因为人们在这些情况下，想要留下积极的印象。他们可能会如实指出某些技能、某些相关的经验、他们可能与面试他们的人的相似之处，但战略性地省略某些信息，或战略性地将对话从任何可能暗示缺乏契合度或缺乏相关技能的领域转移开。
to communicate honestly. But yeah, another example, maybe besides the feedback directly, is when you think of job interviews, because people when they're in these situations, want to make a positive impression. And they may truthfully point out certain skills, certain relevant experiences, similarities they might have with the person interviewing them, but strategically omit certain information, or strategically move the conversation away from any areas that might suggest a lack of fit or a lack of relevant skills.
所以“paltering”与这些其他类型的沟通策略相伴而行，人们试图在某些方面诚实，不做出虚假陈述或撒谎，但同时他们并没有促进对真相的理解。是的，你基本上是在说真话，但没有说出全部真相。完全正确。我们犯的第三种失误或错误只是回避。我们干脆完全避免困难的对话。你能谈谈这个吗？我觉得这一定在组织环境中经常发生，
So Paul Turing goes along with these other kinds of communication tactics where people are trying to be honest in some ways, not make false statements or lie, but at the same time they're not fostering understanding of the truth. Yeah, you're sort of telling the truth, but not telling the whole truth, basically. Exactly. A third kind of misstep or error we make is just avoidance. We simply avoid difficult conversations altogether. Can you talk about this? I feel this must happen all the time in organizational settings,
家庭环境、人际交往环境中。这发生在你身上过吗，蒂亚？你有没有逃避过进行困难的对话并完全避免它？我想我不是那种会回避的人。所以，我认为对我来说，挑战更多在于如何将仁慈和友善融入到诚实和直率中。
family settings, interpersonal settings. Has this ever happened to you, Taya? Have you ever shirked from having a difficult conversation and avoided it altogether? I'm not one for avoidance, I would say. So that's, I think, for me, the challenge is more on figuring out how to incorporate the benevolence and kindness into the honesty and directness.
以及理解回避何时可能是一个好的策略，何时某些事情最好不说。所以试图弄清楚什么真正能帮助那个人或我们的关系。当有有用的信息时，当那能帮助那个人时，诚实将是重要的和最好的策略。并且它将
And also understanding when avoidance might be a good strategy, when certain things might be better left unsaid. And so trying to figure out what really will help the person or our relationship. Honesty is going to be important and the best strategy when there's useful information, when that could help the person. And it's going
在人们回避对话或不沟通时特别具有破坏性。诚实地说，那些信息可能是有帮助的。但有些情况下，最好不要分享你所想的一切，或者当然不要在某些时刻分享它，因为在那些时刻分享可能不合适。嗯。所以你会争辩说，在某些方面，告诉你的妈妈她穿的裙子不太合适，
to be particularly damaging when people avoid conversations or don't communicate. Honestly, that information could be helpful. But there's some situations where it may be better to not share everything you're thinking or certainly not sharing it in certain moments when it might not be appropriate to do so. Mm-hmm. So you would argue in some ways, telling your mom that the dress she was wearing was not quite right,
允许她进去换裙子。但如果你评论，你知道，她外表的某个方面，她无法改变，那可能仍然是诚实的反馈，但它可能不是特别有用。是的，我完全同意。我认为那将是有害的和破坏性的，
allows her to go in and change her dress. But if you commented, you know, in some aspect of her appearance, that she couldn't change, that might still be honest feedback, but it might not be particularly useful. Yeah, I agree completely. I think that would be harmful and damaging,
给人们关于他们无法改变的事情的反馈，要么是因为他们在那一刻无法改变。在某人工作演示前五分钟，你不会告诉他们这很糟糕，而且他们对此无能为力。但如果还有一天或更长时间，他们仍然可以做出改变，那就是诚实有帮助的时候。
giving people feedback about things they can't change, either because they can't change in that moment. Five minutes before someone's presentation at work, you don't tell them that it's awful and there's nothing they can do about it. But if there's a day or more, where they can still make changes, that's when the honesty is helpful.
人们穿的衣服或外表或其他类似的事情也是如此。如果一个人对此无能为力，那么最好不要提它，至少在那时不要提。现在，我们做所有这些事情。我们撒谎，我们误导，我们“paltering”，我们回避，因为我们确信如果我们说真话，事情就会分崩离析。在某些方面，流行文化支持我们，在电影《大话王》中，一名律师经历了一次转变，他被迫始终说真话。我想让你听听这段片段，亲爱的。艾伦先生，你记得弗莱彻吗？哦，是的。是的，很高兴再次见到你，弗莱彻？哦，是的！是的，很高兴再次见到你，弗莱彻。我一直听到关于你的一些好消息。
Same thing with closed people are wearing or appearance or other things along those lines. If there's nothing a person can do about it, then best not to raise it, at least then. Now, we do all of these things. We lie, we're mislead, we paltry, we avoid, because we're sure that things will fall apart if we tell the truth. And in some ways, popular culture backs us up in the movie Liar Liar, a lawyer undergoes a transformation where he is compelled to tell the truth at all times. I want you to listen to this clip, dear. Mr. Allen, you remember Fletcher? Oh, yes. Yes, nice to see you again, Fletcherie? Oh, yeah! Yeah, it's nice to see you again, Fletcher. I've been hearing some good things about you.
好吧，弗莱彻刚刚告诉我他有多看重你。但你为什么不告诉奥特先生呢？他是个迂腐的、自以为是的、自命不凡的混蛋。一个好战的老混蛋，一堆毫无价值的冒着热气的牛粪。想如果我们说话的话。所以在这部电影中，当吉姆·凯瑞开始对每个人脱口而出真相时，他的生活确实分崩离析了。现在蒂亚，你最近进行了一项研究，你让志愿者说出他们的想法，但也许没有吉姆·凯瑞那么残忍。
Well, Fletcher has just been telling me how much he thinks of you. But why don't you tell Mr. Out? He's a pedantic, pontificating pretentious bastard. A belligerent old fart, a worthless steaming pile of cow-dum. Figured if we speak. So in the movie Jim Carrey's life does fall apart when he starts blurting out the truth to everyone. Now Tanya, you recently conducted a study in which you had volunteers speak their minds, but perhaps without the same cruelty as Jim Carrey did.
告诉我你给志愿者们的指示。我在这方面工作的第一项研究是与现在在芝加哥大学的埃米尔·莱文教授合作的。在这个研究中，她是费城宾夕法尼亚大学的博士生，我们在费城进行了一项我们称之为“挑战练习研究”的研究。我们说，在接下来的三天里，在你与
Tell me about the instructions you gave your volunteers. The first study that I worked on in this area is with Professor Emil Levine, who is now at University of Chicago. And this one, she was a doctoral student at University of Pennsylvania in Philadelphia, and we ran a study in Philadelphia that we called the Challenging Exercise Study. And we said, throughout the next three days, be honest in every conversation you have with
你交谈的每一个人进行的每一次对话中都要诚实。在与他人分享你的想法、感受、意见时，真的尝试完全坦诚和开放。这可能很困难，但尽你最大的努力去诚实。在我们让人们走进世界并在他们所有的对话中保持诚实之前，我们让他们预测他们认为这会是什么样子。对，他们说了什么？
every person you talk to. Really try to be completely candid and open when you're sharing your thoughts, feelings, opinion with others. It may be difficult, but try your best to be honest. And before we had people go out into the world and be honest in all their conversations, we had them predict what they thought this would be like. Right, what did they say?
总的来说，人们认为这会是一次非常糟糕的经历，不会令人愉快，会损害我的社会关系，会有害。总的来说，人们认为这会是一次非常不愉快的经历。发生的事情恰恰相反。人们认为这会是一次非常不愉快的经历。发生的事情恰恰相反。它比人们预期的要愉快得多，它对关系有帮助，创造了强大的社会联系，人们对这种经历有多么解放或有意义相当准确。但总的来说，
Overall, people thought this was gonna be a pretty terrible experience, gonna be unenjoyable, going to damage my social relationships, be harmful. Overall, people thought this was going to be a pretty unpleasant experience. What happened was the exact opposite. people thought this was going to be a pretty unpleasant experience. What happened was the exact opposite. It was much more enjoyable than people anticipated that it was helpful for the relationships, created a strong social connection, and people were reasonably accurate on how liberating or meaningful the experience was. But overall,
这对研究参与者来说是令人惊讶的，对我们来说也是令人惊讶的。因为当我们计划这项研究时，我们没有预料到诚实会有如此戏剧性的积极影响。这些回应，我们请配音演员为我们朗读，揭示了诚实的反馈可以在多大程度上改变关系的轨迹。一个令人难忘的例子是一位女性在研究过程中与她的男朋友分手了。
it was surprising to the participants in the study and it was surprising to us as well. Because when we planned the study, we weren't expecting such a dramatic, positive impact of honesty. The responses, which we asked voice actors to read for us, reveal the extent to which honest feedback can change the trajectory of a relationship. One memorable example was a woman who broke up with her boyfriend over the course of the study.
哦，天哪。但她对此感到非常宽慰，因为她一直推迟进行这次困难的对话。她写道，这影响了我与男朋友的关系。我告诉了他关于我有时感受的真相，这导致了我们的分手。尽管这很困难，但她仍然很高兴终于能够做到这一点。它向我们强调了，即使当我们进行这些困难的对话时，事情并不总是进展顺利，她仍然对这次经历心存感激，因为这是需要发生的事情。另一个人分享说，你知道，当我不需要对我对某些事情的想法撒谎，或者在我没有感觉好的时候说我感觉很好时，我感觉不那么虚伪了。我和室友之间的紧张关系真的在加剧，因为我无法让自己告诉她她做的那些令人讨厌的事情。在做这项研究时，我告诉了她所有我长期以来一直避免告诉她的事情。这感觉有点解放。
Oh my gosh. But she was feeling so relieved by it because she'd been putting off having this difficult conversation. And she wrote that it affected my relationship with my boyfriend. I told him the truth about how I felt sometimes, which led to our breakup. Even though this was hard, she was so happy to be able to finally do this. And it highlighted to us how even when we have these difficult conversations where things you
有些事情有点尴尬，但其他事情感觉很好，它确实有助于缓解一些紧张。我了解到，说出那些事情比把它们憋在心里直到爆炸感觉更好。蒂亚研究的结果在志愿者在工作场所给出诚实反馈时同样具有戏剧性。一个人分享说，当诚实让我在职位和组织中走得更远时，我特别惊讶，因为表达我诚实的意见让其他人更多地思考情况
know don't always work out well that she was still grateful for the experience because it was something that needed to happen. Another person shared, you know I felt less fake when I didn't have to lie about what I thought about some things or say I felt fine when I didn't. Tension was really building up with my roommate because I couldn't bring myself to tell her the things she was doing that were annoying. And while doing this study, I told her all those things I'd been avoiding to tell her for a long while. And it felt kind of liberating.
并得出和我一样的结论。另一个人分享说。人们的反应与我想象的不同。他们喜欢并欣赏这种诚实，老实说，我不相信会发生这种情况。这令人耳目一新，意味着我很高兴谈论我脑海中的事情，而不必担心别人怎么说。换句话说，志愿者报告说，他们的关系不仅在他们花72小时对他人诚实的过程中得以维持，而且蓬勃发展。我们问人们是否
Some of the things were kind of awkward, but others felt good, and it did help ease some of the tension. I learned that it feels better to say those things instead of keeping them inside until it explodes. The results of TAAS study were just as dramatic when volunteers gave honest feedback in the workplace. One person shared, I was particularly surprised when being honest got me further in my position and in an organization because voicing my honest opinion made others think about the situation
欣赏这次经历，你知道，长期利益，两周后，伤害，关系改善。在所有这些领域，人们都说这次经历帮助了他们的关系和他们的幸福。有趣的一点是，我们在研究中有一个类似的条件，一个平行的条件，而不是要求人们三天保持诚实，我们要求他们保持友善并优先考虑友善。在友善的情况下，人们认为那会是一次相当不错的经历，结果确实如此，但对于诚实，人们预料到这对关系不会很好，但事实上它确实很好，而且他们说它甚至比我们要求在所有沟通中保持友善的人更积极。
more and come to the conclusion that I was thinking as well. Another person shared. People reacted differently than what I thought. They liked and appreciated the honesty, and honestly, I did not believe that was going to happen. It was refreshing, a meaning that I was happy to talk about what was on my mind and not worry about what was said. In other words, the volunteers reported that their relationships not only endured the 72 hours they spent being honest with others, they thrived. We asked people whether they
所以我了解到你用另一项研究跟进了这项研究，你要求志愿者带着他们的一位亲密伴侣来到实验室。你在这项研究中试图做什么，带我了解一下发生了什么？所以，第一项研究的局限性之一是我们不知道人们确切谈论了什么，或者对话是如何展开的，
appreciated the experience, you know, the long-term benefits, two weeks later, the harm, the relational improvements. And in all these areas, people said the experience helped their relationships and their well-being. One thing that was interesting was that we had a similar condition, a parallel condition in the study where rather than asking people to be honest for three days, we asked them to be kind and prioritize kindness. In the case of kindness, people thought that would be a pretty good experience and it turned out it was, but with honesty, people anticipated that it would not be great for the relationships, but in fact it was and they said it was even more positive than those for whom we asked to be kind in all their communications.
他们与谁沟通。所以我们想进入一个实验室环境中的受控研究，在那里我们可以让人们提前写下他们要说的话，然后阅读这些回应，然后记录互动。所以我们，在最初的研究之后进行了几项后续研究，我们让成对的成年人
So I understand that you followed up this study with another one where you asked volunteers to come into a lab with one of their close partners. What were you trying to do in this study and walk me through what happened? So, one of the limitations of the first study was we didn't know exactly what people spoke about or the conversations, how they unfolded,
来到实验室，我们让他们预测进行一次诚实的反馈对话会是什么样子。然后我们让他们进行对话。所以你实际上让人们在你在实验室时进行了这些对话？是的，他们必须向来到实验室的人提供一条关键反馈。我们要求他们分享关于一件事的诚实意见、感受、反应。
who they were communicating with. So we wanted to then move on to a controlled study in a laboratory setting where we could have people write out in advance what they were going to say, and then read those responses, and then record the interactions. And so we, ran several follow-up studies after the initial ones where we had pairs of adults
你认为这个人应该做些不同的事情，改变自己，或加以改进，并且他们必须大声朗读他们的信息并与他们的伴侣就此进行对话。我想象人们对做这样的事情有很大的焦虑。是的，当我们要求他们预测这会是什么样子时，他们不认为这会特别令人愉快，他们不认为这对关系会很好，而且他们预料到他们的朋友或伴侣会对此做出负面反应。
come into the lab and we had them anticipate what it would be like to have an honest feedback conversation. And then we had them have the conversation. And so you actually had people have these conversations while you were present in the lab? Yes, they had to provide one piece of critical feedback to the person that came to the lab with. We asked them to share their honest opinions, feelings, reactions about one thing.
他们的伴侣会对此做出负面反应。志愿者与伴侣分享的反馈范围从常规到非凡。你需要更多地打扫公寓。你也需要对出现的问题更合乎逻辑和高效。我认为你可以努力变得更有准备和更准时，以避免像今天这样的情况。当你做出承诺时，你应该弄清楚如何让自己准备好去履行那个承诺。你知道，我认为你应该努力改善你感到沮丧或恼火时的冲动反应和回应。
You think this person should do differently, change about themselves, or improve upon, and that they would have to read their message aloud and engage in a conversation with their partner about it. I'm imagining that people had significant anxiety about doing something like this. Yes, when we asked them to predict what this would be like, they didn't think this would be particularly enjoyable, they didn't think this would be great for the relationship, and they anticipated that their friend or their partner would react negatively to it.
有时你的评论是直率和指责性的，效率较低。效率较低。我认为你可以改进的一件事是你的同理心和同情心。我认为有时你会陷入你自己的感受中，但真正思考别人的意图也很重要。哇，所以这些相当直接。我的意思是，这些是人们通常可能犹豫不谈的事情。所以人们如此直接地对待彼此真是太神奇了。是的，我绝对不认为人们会在没有提示的情况下以这种方式进行这些对话。但类似于第一项研究，人们在所有对话中都很诚实，在
their partner would react negatively to it. The feedback the volunteer shared with their partners ranged from the routine to the remarkable. You need to clean the apartment more. You also need to be more logical and efficient with problems that come up. I think you can work on being more prepared and more punctual to avoid situations like today. When you make a commitment, you should figure out how to get yourself ready to follow through on that commitment. You know, I think you should work on your impulse reactions and responses when you're frustrated or annoyed.
这个研究中，人们预料到他们与之沟通的人会经济上，而他们自己并没有。无论是根据他们如何评价自己，还是根据沟通者如何体验它。你是否再次发现人们因为诚实地表达了他们的想法而感到彼此更亲近了？是的。它带来的强烈的社会联系感将人们聚集在一起，并没有像他们预期的那样将他们分开。你认为为什么会发生这种情况？你认为为什么这些进行这些诚实
Sometimes your comments are blunt and accusational and are less productive. and are less productive. I think one thing you could improve on is your empathy and sympathy. I think sometimes you get caught up in how you feel, but it's also important to really think about other people's intentions. Wow, so these were fairly direct. I mean, these are the kinds of things that people might hesitate to talk about in general to you. So it's quite amazing that people were so direct with one another. Yes, I definitely don't think people would have had these conversations in this way unprompted. But similar to the first study where people were honest in all their conversations, in
对话或直率对话或根据你的措辞选择的直率对话？你认为为什么这些实际上增加了人与人之间的亲密感？我认为这是因为在这些对话中，很明显，来到研究的人确实关心他们。即使那个人沟通得很直率或直接说出事情，他们仍然在提供最终可以帮助他们的反馈。[♪ 背景音乐播放，播放问题并不是真的关于它是否更好]
this one, people anticipated that the person that they were communicating with was going to be economically, and the person themselves did not. Both according to how they evaluated themselves and how the communicator experienced it as well. And did you find again here that people felt closer to one another as a result of having expressed their thoughts honestly? Yes. The strong sense of social connection that it brought people together and did not drive them apart in the way that they expected. Why do you think that's happening? Why do you think that these having these honest
这一次，人们预料到他们交流的对象会从经济角度考虑，但对方并没有。这既符合他们对自己的评价，也符合交流者本人的体验。你是否再次发现，人们因为坦诚表达了自己的想法而感到彼此更加亲近了？是的。这种强烈的社会联系感将人们凝聚在一起，并没有像他们预期的那样将他们分开。你认为这是为什么？你认为为什么进行这些诚实的
conversations or blunt conversations or fore-threat conversations depending on your choice of words? Why do you think these were actually increasing the intimacy between people? I think it's because during these conversations, it was clear that the person that came to the study with really did care about them. And even if that person was communicating bluntly or saying things directly, they were still providing them with feedback that could ultimately help them. [♪ Music playing in background, playing see the question was not really about whether it was better to
对话，或者直率的对话，又或是根据你的措辞选择的“预警”对话？你认为为什么这些对话实际上增加了人与人之间的亲密度？我认为这是因为在这些对话中，很明显对方确实关心他们。即使那个人说话直率或直言不讳，他们仍然在提供最终能帮助到对方的反馈。[♪ 背景音乐响起，问题其实不在于是否更好]
be honest or better to be kind. It was possible to be both at the same time. She started to evaluate communication strategies that could allow people to honour both moral imperatives simultaneously. When we come back, three principles to keep in mind, when you are debating whether to give someone difficult feedback. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In daily life, all of us confront a problem in our interactions.
是该诚实还是该善良。其实两者可以兼得。她开始评估各种沟通策略，希望能让人们同时兼顾这两种道德准则。稍后回来，我们将分享在考虑是否要给他人提供尖锐反馈时，需要牢记的三个原则。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在日常生活中，我们所有人在人际交往中都会面临一个问题。
How blunt should we be in our dealings with others? How forthright do we want others to be with us? At Carnegie Mellon University, psychologists, TAEA co-insteadies, how we can communicate more effectively without sacrificing either honesty or kindness. TAEA, one of the things that I took away from the experiments that you conducted,
我们在与他人打交道时应该有多直率？我们希望别人对我们有多坦诚？在卡内基梅隆大学，心理学家泰亚·科恩研究了我们如何在不牺牲诚实或善良的前提下进行更有效的沟通。泰亚，从你所做的实验中，我学到的一点是，
perhaps one of the more striking things, is not just that people were wrong in anticipating that these conversations would be very difficult when they gave, you know, difficult feedback to people, but that the people receiving the feedback were often, if not enthusiastic, at least willing to accept the feedback. Can you talk a little bit about this idea, how many of us underestimate how hungry others are for feedback, including negative feedback. Yes, we underestimate others desire for constructive feedback. As feedback givers, we think a lot about the person's reaction
也许最引人注目的一点是，人们在给出（你知道的）尖锐反馈时，往往错误地预判了这些对话会非常困难，而实际上，接收反馈的人即使算不上热情，至少也愿意接受这些反馈。你能谈谈这个观点吗？我们中有多少人低估了他人对反馈（包括负面反馈）的渴望？是的，我们低估了他人对建设性反馈的渴望。作为反馈的提供者，我们过多地考虑了对方的反应，
what they're going, how they're going to respond and whether the person will want this feedback or not. And we're often wrong about how much the other person would want to know. Think of this as technique number one in having difficult conversations. When you feel you want to communicate something tough to someone else, and you hear a voice inside your head telling you the other person won't want to hear your criticism, remind yourself that most feedback recipients want critical feedback even if it makes them unhappy. That's because even more than wanting to avoid unpleasant news, most of us instinctively
考虑他们会怎么做、怎么回应，以及他们是否想要这些反馈。而我们往往错误地估计了对方想要了解真相的程度。把这当作进行艰难对话的第一条技巧吧。当你觉得想对别人说些难听的话，而脑海中有一个声音告诉你对方不想听你的批评时，提醒自己：大多数反馈接收者都想要批判性的反馈，即使这会让他们不开心。这是因为，比起逃避不愉快的新闻，我们大多数人本能地
understand that unpleasant news can be useful. It isn't fun to receive a bad grade on a school paper or to hear that your outfit isn't quite working. But most people would say that given the choice, they'd prefer to know about the problem. Elaine in the TV show Signed Felt may not be happy to hear that everyone thinks she is a bad dancer, but that doesn't mean she doesn't want to know how others really see her. Is that bad? Have you ever seen yourself? I think one big reason people don't communicate honestly is because they focus on the social
明白不愉快的新闻可能是有用的。在学校作业中拿到差评，或者听说你的穿着不太合适，这确实不愉快。但大多数人会说，如果可以选择，他们宁愿知道问题所在。电视剧《宋飞正传》里的伊莱恩可能不喜欢听到大家都觉得她舞跳得不好，但这并不意味着她不想知道别人眼中的她是什么样。那很糟糕吗？你见过自己吗？我认为人们不诚实沟通的一个重要原因是，他们只关注社交
harm and the negative emotions and that leads them to neglect, to think about all of these benefits that could be provided and just how much the other person might want to learn from them and need that information. So another way to not see honesty and benevolence and conflict with each other is to remember that although tough feedback might be painful in the moment, the benefits show up in the long run. Talk about this tension between the short term and long term benefits of honesty. So the long term benefits of feedback
伤害和负面情绪，这导致他们忽略了思考这些反馈可能带来的所有好处，以及对方可能有多想从他们那里学习并需要这些信息。因此，不把诚实和仁慈视为对立的另一种方法是记住，虽然尖锐的反馈在当下可能会让人痛苦，但其好处会在长远中显现。谈谈诚实的短期利益和长期利益之间的这种张力吧。反馈的长期利益
is that the person could improve. And that's often in the future. Whereas in the present, what is happening in these conversations is often the provision of some kind of negative or critical information. And we have an easier time seeing and thinking about what's happening immediately in front of us, the short-term awkwardness or difficulty of the interaction and the more abstract longer-term benefits are more out of view.
在于对方可以进步。这通常是在未来。而在当下，这些对话中发生的事情往往是提供某种负面或批判性的信息。我们更容易看到和思考眼前发生的事情，即互动中短期的尴尬或困难，而更抽象的长期利益则被忽视了。
I mean, it's also the case that when we give feedback to others, you know, the unpleasantness of the conversation of offering negative feedback is something that we experience in the moment. The benefits of that feedback is something that the other person might experience over the long term. Could this be another reason in some ways why we might be hesitant to share feedback? Because in some ways, the benefits of that feedback really accrue to the other person, the consequences of that feedback often accrue to us. Yes, I think that's part of it as well. I think the positive consequences can accrue to us when the feedback receiver tells us that what we shared helped them, but sometimes that's not shared, or if it's shared, it's far in the the future and we may not know just how much the comments
我的意思是，当我们给别人反馈时，提供负面反馈的对话所带来的不快是我们当下所经历的。而反馈的好处是对方在长期内可能会体验到的。这是否是我们在分享反馈时可能犹豫不决的另一个原因？因为在某种程度上，反馈的好处确实归于对方，而反馈的后果往往由我们承担。是的，我认为这也是原因之一。我认为当反馈接收者告诉我们，我们分享的内容帮助了他们时，积极的后果也会归于我们，但有时这些反馈并没有被分享，或者即使分享了，也是在很久之后，我们可能不知道我们所做的评论
we made of the feedback we provided helped them. Think of this as technique number two. Remind yourself that even if you happen to be talking to someone who doesn't want to receive negative feedback, there are long-term benefits that could outweigh the short-term costs. Most of us do this instinctively with our children or with elderly parents and grandparents. We realize that sometimes we need to be the bearers of bad news because it's going to have long-term benefits. In fact, we are not honest with the people we love because we dislike them. We are honest precisely because we love them.
或提供的反馈在多大程度上帮助了他们。把这当作第二条技巧。提醒自己，即使你碰巧在和一个不想接受负面反馈的人交谈，长期利益也可能超过短期成本。我们大多数人在对待孩子或年迈的父母和祖父母时，本能地就是这样做的。我们意识到，有时我们需要成为坏消息的传递者，因为这会有长期的好处。事实上，我们对所爱的人诚实并不是因为我们讨厌他们。我们诚实恰恰是因为我们爱他们。
But if the first two techniques are about managing the feelings inside our own heads as givers of feedback, the next technique is to think carefully about the feelings of the feedback recipient. It's not enough for you to know that you are offering feedback because you care about the feelings of the feedback recipient. It's not enough for you to know that you are offering feedback because you care about the other person. You need to make that explicit. I think it's critical that the feedback recipient
但是，如果前两条技巧是关于管理我们作为反馈提供者内心的感受，那么下一条技巧就是仔细考虑反馈接收者的感受。仅仅知道你提供反馈是因为你关心反馈接收者的感受是不够的。仅仅知道你提供反馈是因为你关心对方是不够的。你需要明确表达出来。我认为至关重要的是，反馈接收者
feels supported, meaning that they feel like the other person cares about them, that they feel like they can change, that they can grow. And by communicating your benevolent intentions that you care about the person and that the reason you're telling them is potentially negative things about their behavior is to help them that engenders receptivity. And if the person is then receptive to it, then they can really listen and hear what you're saying and
感到被支持，这意味着他们觉得对方关心他们，觉得他们可以改变，可以成长。通过传达你仁慈的意图——即你关心对方，你告诉他们关于他们行为的潜在负面信息是为了帮助他们——这会激发他们的接受度。如果对方因此变得乐于接受，那么他们就能真正倾听并理解你所说的话，并
then learn from the interaction. However, where people go wrong, or feedback viewers go wrong, is they think, well, the way to make the person receptive is to simply tell them nice things or praise them, general positive statements. And I think that is very different than conveying support and responsiveness to the person you're giving feedback to. I understand that research has suggested that expressing benevolent intentions might be especially important when the relationship is one that could be corroded by mistrust,
从互动中学习。然而，人们（或反馈提供者）犯错的地方在于，他们认为让对方乐于接受的方法仅仅是告诉他们好听的话或赞美他们，即泛泛的正面陈述。我认为这与向你提供反馈的对象传达支持和响应是非常不同的。我了解到研究表明，表达仁慈的意图在关系可能因不信任而受到侵蚀时尤为重要，
for example, a relationship between a white teacher and a black student. Can you tell us about research along these lines carried out by the psychologists David Yeager and his colleagues? Yes, they've developed an intervention they call wise feedback and they're highlighting this importance of support rather than praise. And this team of researchers has been some work with children in schools where they've changed how critical feedback is framed, and specifically reframing it to highlight that the feedback giver has very high expectations, and that they believe that the feedback recipient can meet those expectations. So they've used comments like, I'm giving you these comments because I have very high expectations and I know that you can reach them. And they found this is particularly affected for
例如，白人教师和黑人学生之间的关系。你能告诉我们心理学家大卫·耶格及其同事在这方面所做的研究吗？是的，他们开发了一种他们称之为“明智反馈”的干预措施，他们强调了支持而非赞美的重要性。这个研究团队在学校里与孩子们进行了一些工作，他们改变了批判性反馈的框架，具体来说，是重新构建了反馈，以强调反馈提供者有非常高的期望，并且他们相信反馈接收者能够达到这些期望。所以他们使用了这样的评论：“我给你这些评论是因为我有很高的期望，我知道你能达到。”他们发现这对
groups of students who may not have a lot of trust in their teachers or the schools or who may not be feel supported in other ways. And I think it relates to this idea of being receptive to the feedback, because it's become clear why the feedback giver is providing those comments. And also it's removing these barriers to receptivity, because they're not defensive, because it's not as much of a threat. So in other words, if I'm giving feedback instead of saying, you know, do X or do Y, it might be important to preface that by saying, I really think that you are capable of doing X and Y, and here are my suggestions on how you can reach those high targets. Yes. Highlighting that you believe they're capable of reaching them, that the goal of you providing feedback is to help the feedback recipient reach their goals, and that you're responsive to their needs and what they're looking for.
那些可能对老师或学校缺乏信任，或者在其他方面感到没有得到支持的学生群体特别有效。我认为这与乐于接受反馈的理念有关，因为反馈提供者提供这些评论的原因变得清晰了。而且，这也消除了接受反馈的障碍，因为他们不会感到防御，因为这不再是一种威胁。换句话说，如果我在提供反馈时，与其说“做这个或做那个”，不如先说“我真的认为你有能力做到这一点，以下是我关于你如何达到这些高目标的建议”，这可能很重要。是的。强调你相信他们有能力达到目标，你提供反馈的目的是帮助反馈接收者实现他们的目标，并且你对他们的需求和他们所寻求的东西做出响应。
You know, it's striking as we're talking, you know, I'm seeing how subtle these conversations need to be. I think many of us rush into feedback conversations either, you know, doing the things we discussed earlier. We, you know, avoid, or we paltryry or we mislead or we offer unnecessary praise, you know, or we just sort of blunder in and just sort of say everything that's on our minds. And I think really the picture that you're painting here is a picture that requires a fair amount of time and nuance and patience in order to communicate feedback both honestly,
你知道，当我们交谈时，我发现这些对话需要多么微妙，这令人震惊。我认为我们许多人匆忙进入反馈对话，要么（你知道的）做我们之前讨论过的事情。我们（你知道的）回避，或者我们敷衍，或者我们误导，或者我们提供不必要的赞美，（你知道的），或者我们只是笨拙地闯入，把脑子里想的一切都说出来。我认为你在这里描绘的画面确实需要相当多的时间和细微差别以及耐心，才能既诚实地传达反馈，
effectively, but also benevolently. Yes, and it can be very challenging when our time is limited, when we have lots of different obligations. And so sometimes we just have a quick conversation and we say things, the other side doesn't fully understand the context of it, or we don't fully communicate that the reason we're giving these comments is for them to improve. And so a lot of problems, I think, can arise when we are communicating quickly or without thinking through how to best incorporate the support that's needed to provide the feedback along with the honesty. And so that that can lead us to just avoid having these conversations all together because they're hard. I'm wondering if this has happened to you, Tia. Have you had
又有效，同时也仁慈。是的，当我们的时间有限，当我们有许多不同的义务时，这可能非常具有挑战性。所以有时我们只是进行简短的对话，我们说了一些话，对方并没有完全理解其中的背景，或者我们没有完全传达出我们提供这些评论的原因是为了让他们进步。因此，我认为当我们沟通得太快，或者没有仔细考虑如何最好地结合提供反馈所需的支持与诚实时，就会出现很多问题。这可能导致我们完全避免进行这些对话，因为它们太难了。泰亚，我想知道这是否发生在你身上？你是否有过
situations where you're in a rush and someone's asking you for feedback, either professionally or personally, and in some ways the the constraint of time makes it actually difficult to provide feedback with the nuance that is required. Yes, so I certainly struggle with this when providing feedback over email and I find it's much easier for me to communicate kindness and support and and tact and other things when it's accompanied by a face-to-face conversation or on the phone, it's supposed to just written. So I will find myself kind of sending short emails, change this, do this, whether it's to my doctoral students or others I work with.
在匆忙中，有人向你寻求反馈（无论是专业上还是个人上）的情况，在某种程度上，时间的限制使得提供带有必要细微差别的反馈变得困难？是的，当通过电子邮件提供反馈时，我确实为此挣扎。我发现当有面对面的谈话或电话交流时，我更容易传达善良、支持、机智和其他东西，而不是仅仅通过书面形式。所以我发现自己会发送简短的电子邮件，比如“修改这个”、“做这个”，无论是对我的博士生还是其他与我共事的人。
And I'm hoping they recognize that it's just about ways I think we can improve our work together. But I think it's also important to recognize that I don't know the person receiving that email when it's just a simple short, you know, the person receiving that email when it's just a simple short TURCE email, are they understanding, you know, that I have been able and intentions toward them that I really believe they can make things better and it's not an attack on their work. Yeah, and especially in sort of these very TURCE communications, you know, you're stripping out a lot of the human elements, you know, and we need to do that.
我希望他们能认识到，这只是我认为我们可以改进工作方式的方法。但我认为同样重要的是要认识到，当它只是一封简单、简短、生硬的电子邮件时，我并不了解接收这封邮件的人，他们是否理解（你知道的）我对他们怀有善意，我真的相信他们可以让事情变得更好，而不是对他们工作的攻击。是的，特别是在这种非常生硬的沟通中，（你知道的），你剥离了很多人性元素，（你知道的），我们需要这样做。
We need to sort of use these technologies in the interest of efficiency in professional situations, especially. But I can see how easily you can strip out the human element of this and convey the wrong impression. Right. Because misunderstandings are likely to arise when we're communicating only in a written format, when we lose a lot of information about the tone, about the context of the comments.
我们确实需要在专业情况下为了效率而使用这些技术。但我可以看到，你很容易剥离其中的人性元素，并传达错误的印象。没错。因为当我们只用书面形式交流时，当我们丢失了关于语气、评论背景的大量信息时，很可能会产生误解。
And increasingly, as we do more of our work over email, I think this is something to keep in mind that especially when providing feedback, it can be difficult to do when it's only in written format, when it's not accompanied by a conversation. So we talked earlier about how people from different cultures and different countries might have different notions of what's appropriate and conversations. In the example you gave me earlier where you wrote to the chair of the conference, I believe, you know, this was someone from another country and there could have been a misunderstanding here because in fact you had different, you know, background norms of how honest and forthright you were supposed to be in conversations.
而且随着我们越来越多地通过电子邮件工作，我认为这一点需要牢记，特别是在提供反馈时，当它只以书面形式进行，没有对话伴随时，这可能很难做到。所以我们之前谈到了来自不同文化和国家的人可能对对话中什么是适当的有不同的概念。在你之前给我的例子中，你写信给会议主席，我相信（你知道的），这是一个来自另一个国家的人，这里可能存在误解，因为事实上你们有不同的（你知道的）关于在对话中应该多么诚实和直率的背景规范。
I'm wondering how you navigate that divide. When we're communicating across cultures or with people from different countries, how does the same advice to both be benevolent and to be honest? How does that work? Can't we run into problems where other people have very different scales in terms of how much honesty and how much benevolence they expect. One thing I've learned in doing research on honesty is that there's a difference between being honest and being direct. And I think all cultures throughout the world value to a high degree, they value honesty and benevolence, right? These are values, maybe there's some variation, but where we see a lot of cultural differences
我想知道你是如何驾驭这种分歧的。当我们跨文化交流或与来自不同国家的人交流时，既要仁慈又要诚实的建议是如何起作用的？我们难道不会遇到这样的问题吗：其他人对于他们期望多少诚实和多少仁慈有着非常不同的衡量标准。在研究诚实的过程中，我学到的一件事是，诚实和直接是有区别的。我认为世界各地的所有文化都在很大程度上重视诚实和仁慈，对吧？这些是价值观，也许有一些差异，但我们看到很多文化差异的地方
is around directness and communication. And it is certainly possible to be honest while still communicating somewhat indirectly. But what can happen in those situations, especially if people are from different cultures where they, they're not aware of all the cues and they're not necessarily understanding one another, is misunderstandings can arise
是在直接性和沟通方面。在保持诚实的同时，以某种间接的方式进行沟通当然是可能的。但在这些情况下，特别是如果人们来自不同的文化，他们不了解所有的暗示，也不一定能理解对方，误解就可能产生，
because the part didn't understand the indirect cues that people were using to communicate that information. And so I think we can differentiate the content of the communication, whether it is truthful or not. And that's when I think we can differentiate the content of the communication, whether it is truthful or not, and that's what I think of honesty. It's along those lines often, but from the way in which the information is communicated. And the communicator has a responsibility to communicate in a way that the recipient understands. And when people are communicating across cultures
因为对方没有理解人们用来传达该信息的间接暗示。所以我认为我们可以区分沟通的内容，即它是否真实。这就是我认为可以区分沟通内容的地方，无论它是否真实，这就是我所认为的诚实。它通常是沿着这些路线的，但与信息传达的方式不同。沟通者有责任以接收者能理解的方式进行沟通。当人们跨文化交流时
or communicating in ways that are more indirect, that can be challenging. You know, I recently came by this website. It was a satirical website that looked at the way people in Britain and people in America use English. And it had sort of a translator, which basically said this is what it means when British people say X and this is what they actually mean and you know one of the things it says is when British people say quite good what they really mean is that this is not good and when they say you know with the greatest respect what they really mean is what you're saying is idiotic so there are differences between cultures in how direct people are willing
或者以更间接的方式进行沟通时，这可能具有挑战性。你知道，我最近偶然发现了这个网站。这是一个讽刺网站，观察英国人和美国人使用英语的方式。它有一种翻译器，基本上说当英国人说“相当好”时，它的意思是这是不好的；当他们说“恕我直言”时，它的意思是“你说的简直是白痴”。所以，即使在表达诚实的反馈时，不同文化在人们愿意表现得多么直接方面也存在差异。
to be even when they're expressing honest feedback. Yes, I think that's absolutely right. I think one common example that my students sometimes share when I teach about negotiations is, you know, when you are communicating with people in other cultures and you say, well, will this be done on time? And sometimes people might say, oh, yeah, sure, yes, knowing full well the answer is no, but they wouldn't want to say no because that might communicate a lack of respect, right? Because they're trying to communicate that benevolence and they wouldn't want to disrespect others. And they assume that the other person should know that the answer they're giving is not true.
是的，我认为这绝对正确。我认为当我在教授谈判课程时，我的学生有时会分享一个常见的例子，（你知道的），当你与来自其他文化的人交流时，你说：“这能按时完成吗？”有时人们可能会说：“哦，是的，当然，好的”，明知答案是否定的，但他们不想说“不”，因为那可能传达出缺乏尊重，对吧？因为他们试图传达那种仁慈，他们不想不尊重他人。而且他们认为对方应该知道他们给出的答案是不真实的。
And lots of misunderstanding to rise because the one side is saying, you should understand what I really meant by that response. Right. And then the other side is saying, well, you told me you would get this done, or that you would respond to this. And so we're trying to understand what do these words really mean. And you can easily see how both sides of that could feel they were being honest while thinking the other side was not.
而且会产生很多误解，因为一方说：“你应该明白我那个回答的真正含义。”没错。然后另一方说：“好吧，你告诉我你会完成这个，或者你会回应这个。”所以我们试图理解这些词到底是什么意思。你可以很容易地看出，双方都可能觉得自己在诚实，同时认为对方并不诚实。
What do you think of the other side? After spending years researching the psychology of unpleasant feedback, Tia once found herself in the kind of situation, she often sets up for volunteers in her experiments. She was confronting the possibility of a difficult conversation. All the usual concerns that her volunteers had now sprang to her mind. So this was a recent experience where a colleague who I didn't know very well
你觉得对方怎么样？在花了多年时间研究不愉快反馈的心理学后，泰亚有一次发现自己处于那种她经常为实验志愿者设置的情况中。她正面临着一场艰难对话的可能性。她志愿者所担心的所有常见问题现在都浮现在她的脑海中。所以这是最近的一次经历，一位我不怎么熟悉的同事
had reached out to me about potentially collaborating. He had some ideas and you'd had an initial call and then he sent me the paper. And going into this meeting, I was feeling like it was going to be awful. All the things I kind of had talked about in my research where people think these honest conversations could go really badly, because I had some critical thoughts about the paper.
联系我，谈论潜在的合作。他有一些想法，我们进行了一次初步通话，然后他把论文发给了我。在参加这次会议时，我觉得这会很糟糕。我研究中谈到的所有事情，人们认为这些诚实的对话可能会变得非常糟糕，因为我对这篇论文有一些批判性的想法。
Things I thought that could be changed or needed to be changed, reframing, things that didn't make sense to me, a major work would be needed. And so I didn't know this person very well. So I wasn't sure just how direct should I be, how much should I communicate, maybe this isn't what the person wanted, maybe they did. But it asked for my feedback and I really value honesty.
我认为可以改变或需要改变的事情，重新构思，我不理解的事情，需要大量的工作。所以我不太了解这个人。所以我不知道我应该表现得多么直接，我应该传达多少，也许这不是对方想要的，也许他们想要。但他要求我提供反馈，我非常重视诚实。
So I figured if the person was asking for my feedback or advice, then I would provide it to him. So going in, I was thinking this is going to be a difficult conversation and an unpleasant. I wasn't sure how I should handle it, but I communicated directly about the problems I saw. I also, I think, during the conversation was much better than in my written comments at conveying how I thought there was the seed of something interesting, and then if we made these changes reframed, then the good ideas could come through better. And so what happened rather than him being defensive or upset, he responded, like, wow, this is exactly what I was looking for.
所以我认为如果对方要求我的反馈或建议，那么我会提供给他。所以进去的时候，我想这会是一场艰难且不愉快的对话。我不确定我应该如何处理它，但我直接沟通了我看到的问题。我也认为，在对话中，我比在书面评论中更好地传达了我认为其中有有趣种子的想法，如果我们要进行这些修改和重新构思，那么好的想法就能更好地体现出来。所以发生了什么呢？他没有表现出防御或不安，而是回应说：“哇，这正是我想要的。”
This is so helpful. Yes, I can see that. Thank you. I wasn't aware of that, but now that you say that, I can see these problems. This is really helpful. And it went from the situation where I thought it was going to be terrible or could be terrible. And it ended up being a great experience. And at least what he told me during our call was how helpful it was. And afterwards, it strengthened my relationship, it helped him, and was much more enjoyable than I had anticipated. Teja Cohen is a psychologist at Carnegie Mellon University.
“这太有帮助了。是的，我明白了。谢谢。我之前没意识到，但现在你说了，我能看到这些问题。这真的很有帮助。”情况从我以为会很糟糕或可能很糟糕，最终变成了一次很棒的经历。至少他在通话中告诉我这有多么有帮助。事后，它加强了我们的关系，帮助了他，而且比我预期的要愉快得多。泰亚·科恩是卡内基梅隆大学的心理学家。
Teja, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to Voice Actors Taylor Winkfield and Pedro Fetosa. For today's Unsung Hero, we bring you a story from our sister show, My An Sankiro.
泰亚，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本周特别感谢配音演员泰勒·温克菲尔德和佩德罗·费托萨。今天的“无名英雄”，我们为您带来我们姐妹节目《我的无名英雄》中的一个故事。
Our story comes from John Mo. In the early 90s, John moved to Seattle to follow his dream of becoming a writer or an actor. Instead, he found himself working full-time in customer service at a software company. So I was working at a company called WRQ. It doesn't exist anymore. And it was very detailed, very dry. It wasn't anything fun. But I had undiagnosed.
我们的故事来自约翰·莫。90年代初，约翰搬到西雅图，追随他成为作家或演员的梦想。相反，他发现自己在一家软件公司全职从事客户服务工作。所以我当时在一家叫WRQ的公司工作。它现在不存在了。而且工作非常细致，非常枯燥。一点也不好玩。但我有未确诊的
I'd been dealing with depression for a long time by then. So I just had this inherent belief that other people got to do the cool things. And I had to go get a job that I hated and worked there till I died. I had gotten to know somebody in HR, one of the recruiting people in HR, because previous to that I had worked to a temp agency assigning temps and we had sent temps to this place. So I knew the HR department a little bit. And to get away from my desk, I just,
那时我已经长期患有抑郁症了。所以我有一种内在的信念，认为别人可以做很酷的事情。而我必须找一份我讨厌的工作，在那里工作到死。我认识了人力资源部的一个人，因为在那之前我在一家临时代理机构工作，负责分配临时工，我们曾把临时工送到这个地方。所以我对人力资源部有一点了解。为了离开我的办公桌，我只是，
you know, would go for walks around the building, stopped in to see Jane, this woman in HR. And I'd just say, hey, how's it going? You know, just poking in, saying hi like you do. And she said, oh, well, you know, I'm glad to see you. I was thinking about you. She said, you, well, you know, I'm glad to see I was thinking about you. She said, you remember my husband, Ryan, and I had given Ryan a temp job. She said, you know, Ryan's at Amazon now and they've got some jobs.
（你知道的），会在大楼周围散步，顺便去看看简，人力资源部的那个女人。我会说：“嘿，最近怎么样？”（你知道的），就像你平时那样探头打个招呼。她说：“哦，好吧，（你知道的），很高兴见到你。我刚才还在想你。”她说：“你，好吧，（你知道的），很高兴见到你，我刚才还在想你。”她说：“你还记得我丈夫瑞安吗？”我曾给瑞安一份临时工作。她说：“你知道，瑞安现在在亚马逊，他们有一些职位。”
They have a job coming up that requires somebody who's really creative. And she knew some of the other work I was doing on the side and the theater stuff and the comedy stuff. And I said, Oh, okay. So you want to know if I can think of anybody creative? And she's like, No, no, I mean you. And I said, Well, I don't know. I have a job here. And she said, you don't belong here, which is a hell of a thing to hear someone in HR.
“他们有一个即将出现的职位，需要一个非常有创造力的人。”她知道我私下里做的一些其他工作，比如戏剧和喜剧方面的事情。我说：“哦，好吧。所以你想知道我是否能想到什么有创造力的人？”她说：“不，不，我是指你。”我说：“好吧，我不知道。我在这里有一份工作。”她说：“你不属于这里。”这对于人力资源部的人来说是一句了不起的话。
Say your company. You're meant for something other than this. You're meant to do something else. You should be making your living being creative. And to me, it felt like I had been playing pickup basketball at the YMCA and somebody said, you know, you should, you should play for the Chicago Bulls. Like, it was, it was that ridiculous and idea. I think when someone has no confidence, when someone's beaten themselves down over so many years, which is often the case with depression, that, that one little thing can make such a difference. And I'm welling up right now
“说你的公司。你注定要做别的事情。你注定要做别的事情。你应该靠创造力谋生。”对我来说，这感觉就像我在基督教青年会打野球，有人说：“你知道，你应该为芝加哥公牛队效力。”就像，这太荒谬了。我认为当一个人没有自信时，当一个人多年来一直打击自己时（这在抑郁症患者中很常见），那一件小事就能产生如此大的影响。我现在热泪盈眶
because somebody had seen something in me that I hadn't seen in myself. You know, now I host a show that is very personal, it's about mental health, and I go around the country giving speeches on mental health. I wrote a book called the hilarious World of Depression about my experiences with comedy and mental illness. And all of the stuff that I do requires confidence that what I have to say is worth an audience's time that I should be doing this, that I'm somebody you should listen to. And so I think Jane at WRQ gave me the ladder to get to that height of confidence that
因为有人在我身上看到了我自己没看到的东西。你知道，现在我主持一个非常私人的节目，是关于心理健康的，我走遍全国发表关于心理健康的演讲。我写了一本名为《抑郁症的滑稽世界》的书，讲述了我关于喜剧和精神疾病的经历。我所做的一切都需要自信，即我所说的话值得观众花时间，我应该做这件事，我是你应该倾听的人。所以我认为WRQ的简给了我梯子，让我达到了那种自信的高度，
I need to do all the work that I do today and to help the people I'm able to help. And so now, when I can tell somebody's really good at something and isn't giving themselves credit for it, I've done this with writers who are much less experienced than me, I try to tell them, you're a very good writer, you know, or you're an excellent reporter, because maybe they haven't been told that enough times.
我需要做我今天所做的一切工作，并帮助我能够帮助的人。所以现在，当我能看出某人真的很擅长某事，却不给自己记功时，我对那些经验比我少得多的作家也这样做过，我试着告诉他们：“你是一个非常好的作家，（你知道的），或者你是一位出色的记者”，因为也许他们没有被足够多次地告知这一点。
And that confidence from hearing somebody say that, and I can always tell when I say that, when it's received and goes all the way to their heart, that that's going to give them the confidence to get to the next level. And so that they can get to that point, and they can tell somebody else that at some later point. You know, you have this in you, you can do this. John Moe of St. Paul, Minnesota. He is the host of the podcast, Dupresh Mode. If you enjoy the insights and ideas we feature on Hidden Brain and would like to support our work, please consider becoming a member of our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain
那种听到别人这么说带来的自信，我总能看出当我这么说时，当它被接收并深入他们内心时，那会给他们信心去达到下一个水平。这样他们就能达到那个点，并且在以后的某个时候告诉别人。你知道，你有这个潜力，你可以做到。来自明尼苏达州圣保罗的约翰·莫。他是播客《抑郁模式》的主持人。如果您喜欢我们在《隐藏的大脑》中呈现的见解和想法，并希望支持我们的工作，请考虑成为我们播客订阅《隐藏的大脑》的会员
Plus. You can find Hidden Brain Plus on the Apple Podcasts tab or at apple.co slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Plus。您可以在Apple Podcasts标签页或apple.co/hiddenbrain找到《隐藏的大脑》Plus。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。你 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。